hallo mein name ist nun herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge gott
zu mir later wir befinden uns hier
wieder in der petition und was ich mir
für diese folge überlegt habe war dass
wir keinen großartigen schwarzl machen
ich weiß daraus besteht main kanal
das ist mir selbstverständlich bewusst
allerdings werden wir uns heute mal um
die story kommt mir wird nämlich jedes
man kann sich bei diesem spiel nicht um
die story kümmern ok feinde baumaschinen
löse das ist okay wir machen das jetzt
prangt map alter was ist das denn okay
ich mache jetzt einfach mal the day
trading die deftige sing ich verstehe
dass gerade nicht was heißt ich soll
was macht er denn da auf dem zaun alter
wahrscheinlich schaut ihr das übel gerne
bei anderen youtube die sich hier so
unfassbar toll um die story kümmern
wie geht das jetzt genau ich habe jetzt
einfach mal meine maske aufgesetzt ich
weiß nicht ob die leute denn tanzen
wieder ich muss jetzt erstmal zum casino
laufen ich weiß allerdings nicht genau
wo das ist das wird ja auf der karte
irgendwie nur so total komisch angezeigt
aber ich glaube wir sind das hier sieht
doch aus wie im casino was muss ich
machen hier ist eine baumaschine ich
schau mal nochmal und greife darauf zu
so frank map dann schreck prison break
wird deftig casino was heißt denn dass
ich meine wenn ich hier runter springen
knallig voll auf die wand wir haben es
geschafft ich stecke im baum
ich komme einfach nicht raus leute wo
ist denn dieses verpackte casino alter
ich muss einfach nur irgendwas zu diesem
schalter auf eine neue quest retail and
life center und ich muss irgendwie die
vermisst katzen finden weil sie wohl
irgendwie weg sind aber wo sollen die
sein wir sind auch wieder zwei menschen
die liegen jetzt auf dem boden alter was
soll denn der polizist hier das casino
habe ich immer noch nicht gefunden
wie kann das denn sein alter ich muss
irgend so ein scheiß zum casino bringen
oder oder ist eine rampe die muss ich
definitiv im mitnehmen ich muss dieser
rahmen von lucca so schwer kann
freunde ich bin nur über ein gleis
gefahren jetzt ganz langsam über dieses
gleis hier drüber so dass ich jetzt mit
voll karacho die rampe wo mein gott oh
mein gott okay ich gebe die ganze zeit
vollgas es geht nichts ich kann noch
lenken aber was soll denn die kehlmann
ich hasse diese scheiße hier als ob das
einfach jedes auto macht was über diese
scheiße drüberfährt was tut die ziege
was zum gottes um ein gut wenn du der
ich hab so muskulöse beine das kann
nicht so schwer sein soll ja okay hier
erstmal schön drüber und jetzt sie
gekommen
und das kann doch nicht sein wo in
gottes namen ist in dieses blöde def was
ich dahin bringen muss ich habe jetzt
eine neue quest ausgewählt und zwar muss
ich irgendwas mit job
also dass gamer die eine richtige story
ich habe jetzt ein chocolate beck
genommen macht das ganze jetzt und
feiere jetzt steht hier chocolate
factory completed nächste kurs die ich
mir als herausforderung gesetzt hat
etwas mit diesem gebäude dazu tun
ich weiß noch nicht wie ich da oben hoch
komme ihm da oben hoch zu kommen
brauchen wir glaube ich hilfe von einer
ganz bestimmten person ingo flamingos
berg meine damen und herren links liegt
jetzt erstmal ganz schön da zu dem
gebäude hin denn genau hier müssen ingo
nicht soweit nein nein nein ingo ingo
ingo in going to you can make it dezente
chaos space aber wie mache ich das jetzt
drei wochen später
trade brokers ufo steckt einfach zur
hälfte in dem komischen gebäude dort
drin
und jetzt ist es nahezu komplett in dem
gebäude drin schweizer das ufo steckt
immer noch halb in dem gebäude drin
der fortschritt ist mittlerweile das suv
in einem anderen gebäude drin steckt was
passiert hier ich war noch nie so nahe
dran alle leute die hier oben drauf
standen sind in dem foto oben drin aber
ich weiß immer noch nicht fest hat das
mit scheiß kühn zu tun
tiere die ich steuern kann sind einen
pelikan einen delfin ein lama oder so
und eine ziege aber definitiv keine
warum ist da vorne eine kanone ich bin
in der kanone und kann jetzt
wahrscheinlich mich das hat super
geklappt ich habe versucht einige punks
durchzuführen das hat alles er so medium
geklappt trotzdem würde ich sagen meine
damen und herren
wenn euch das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine positive bewertung
freuen weil sie ideen was ich vielleicht
mal bei glätte noch machen könnte weil
viele wollen dass die spiele weil die
meinen dass es irgendwie witzig ist aber
ich weiß immer nie von was die nächste
folge handeln soll dann schreib mir das
gerne in die kommentare und jetzt
nochmal als dankeschön dafür dass du
gerade so lange zum ende dran geblieben
bist eine kurze ausblick in mauth merge
also muss er diese kombi von maximieren
wir bringen das ganze wahrscheinlich in
einem monat raus hier ganz kurz noch mal
ich hab mal nico geschlagen